it looks like bryce hall and austin
mcbroom
aren't necessarily seeing eye to eye
ahead of their big boxing match
if you like me like me if you know you
know on tuesday the social media stars
faced off during a press conference in
west hollywood
ahead of their celebrity boxing match in
miami on june 12th
but things took a chaotic turn after
austin started to say something
and bryce immediately rushed to his
opponent
and although we only caught a glimpse of
the altercation leave it to social media
stars like tana mojo and harry josie
to show us how crazy things actually got
with both opponents having to be
separated by several people in the crowd
but their beef didn't stop there they
took the aftermath of the fight to
twitter
with austin writing quote come to find
out at bryce hall is as strong
as my ten-month-old baby boy
of course bryce quickly responded
writing glad your security was there to
push me off of you
after i'm done with you i have a better
fight next so i'm not worried
another person chiming in on the drama
english rapper
and youtuber ksi who previously beat
fellow youtube star logan paul in a
boxing match back in 2019
to the winner by split decisions
from the united kingdom
ksi and bryce went back and forth
several times on twitter
but the tweet that got the most traction
was this photo of bryce being pinned
down during the brawl with austin
ksi shared the image and wrote in the
tweet you good
but social media scrutiny is nothing
bryce isn't used to
last june he opened up to et about why
haters on the internet
don't affect him i've been criticized my
whole life growing up
and and even now like when i get hate it
just it doesn't bother me
because i'm just like i've been
criticized my whole life i'm like why do
i care what these people think if you
like me like me if you know you know
how do you handle it or do you not even
really think about it
i've always handled it by um ignoring
like i don't i don't
respond to any hate like when i when i
see it i mean if it's like a flood
a flooded amount of hate i'll like put
my opinion and my perspective on
everything
out there and if you understand what i'm
saying
you do if you if you think i'm still
like that piece of
then go for it like i'm just i never try
to offend someone i always like preach
this too
i'm not a social media influencer i'm a
social media content creator
i never condone any things that i do out
there on social media
and my intentions are never to offend
anyone
it's just i put out content for
entertainment purposes only